[Music]
this year's Shangri-La dialogue a
gathering of Defense officials is taking
place against a backdrop of increasingly
strained U.S China relations
China has set its defense minister
General Lee Xiang Fu will not meet U.S
defense secretary Lloyd Austin because
of U.S actions imposed in 2018 on
General Lee for Russian arms purchases
some analysts say they don't expect ties
to improve quite so quickly U.S China
relationship is really characterized by
competition at the moment and there are
considerable strains diverging interests
and certainly in foreign policy there's
a certain amount of competition for
influence and relationships in the
region and that's of course playing out
on the margins here at the Shangri-La
dialogue just recently the U.S accused a
Chinese fighter jet of carrying out an
aggressive maneuver in international
airspace over the South China Sea China
in response blamed U.S military
reconnaissance activities for being
provocative
Australian prime minister Anthony
albanazi it is keynote address
urged countries in the region to work
collectively to manage the security
challenges ahead there is no security to
be found in isolation no growth or
prosperity to be gained from closing
ourselves off from the world no
stability without respect for
sovereignty no lasting peace without
engaging with each other and working
together
in the next two days officials here will
be listening closely to speeches by
Austin on the US's role in the
asia-pacific region and General Lee on
China's new security initiatives this is
an opportunity for Southeast Asia to
bring the U.S China Europe Australia to
the region and to ask them to make a
statement of defense policy and in doing
that as they're formulating that
statement a lot of these countries they
go through a thought process they want
to know what southeast Asia thinks about
these things
Southeast Asian countries have said they
don't want to have to take sides in the
U.S China rivalry there will likely be
pressure from defense officials from
other countries for the U.S and China to
de-escalate tensions this conference is
an opportunity for defense officials to
repair Old ties and build new ones
towards a common goal stability in the
region Florence Louis Al Jazeera
Singapore